welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm delighted to be joined by
daniel cox
who until very recently was a director
at console partners
dan joins console partners as a trainee
consultant and within 10 years
progressed through the ranks working as
a principal head of division
until he left console partners was the
director of communications
when dan joined the business it was a
progressive startup
and but by the time he left he'd been
part of the incredible growth journey
that led the company to get acquired by
and presario group in 2017.
dan thanks come on the podcast no
worries it's jim good to be on
so where we always like to start in your
opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant i suppose that's
the the magic the magic
question isn't it you know from that
side so um
i think the key characteristics that i
see
over the years is somebody having a why
and i know that might sound a little bit
different but um
the job you know is fun like don't get
me wrong but it's also
very very hard at times you know it's an
emotional roller coaster
um and you know from my point of view
people have got a you know when you're
getting up
at seven in the morning or work until
eight nine o'clock at night
and do it and having to do weekend work
whatever it is to to support your
clients and candidates at times
um when the chips are down you've got to
be able to fall back and say and
understand what what am i actually doing
this for
you know that's not it could be anything
you know and and from my side i'll talk
about my while a little bit more detail
later but
i think that's so so important you know
i see so many people that come into the
business
uh and businesses that speak to other
leaders and they're like
i don't really know why they're joining
recruitment you know and what what do
they want to achieve out of it and i
think that's really really important um
from that side so it doesn't have to be
financial it could be
an array of things but it's really
important that firstly
um outside of main characteristics that
we can discuss it is really
understanding what your why is
now why am i doing it i
love that and then then i suppose on on
the other hand you know hard-working
um determined um
and focused on on hitting goals you know
i think they're the key ones but the key
one for me is you know
really understanding what what you do
and why you're doing it
yeah love that and really quickly
because i know we were talking a bit
before this and you said yeah literally
had a couple of days after you graduated
uni and then
and joined yeah entered the recruitment
industry but yeah
i think people were interested about
this so very quickly then
like did your why change
throughout your career no to be brutally
honest my why
was um you know i was broke like from my
side like most students from that side
others you know
i was thinking of going back into the
into the building trade before
i took the interview with console
partners i was a scaffolder before i
went to university
took a year out and done that and it was
amazing but
i think the cold uh the cold mornings
definitely made me realize right what do
i want to do you know and that's that's
really important and um
that for me resonates really well in
regards to
what what y is you know on the front i
finished university on the friday and um
you know i got the nod a couple of week
weeks before in in in recruitment and
they and
console when they said can you start on
the monday and i was like
yeah let's do it let's go for it you
know i didn't overthink here i think
that let's just go for it
um i needed the money like i mentioned
before i was uh i was
in the red in like most students from
that side so i think yeah
that was that was key yeah
okay so just very quickly then could you
describe
the what the what console partners
looked like when you joined
yeah right which was yeah just just
under 10 years ago
yeah and then just very quickly describe
what it looked like by the time you left
and then i think that would be
great context for people to understand
the journey it's been on then we'll dig
into
the sort of early days and then talk
about the rest of it yeah absolutely so
walk through the doors there was
probably i think it was about 16 people
um if that there was there was three
main divisions at the time sort of like
content communications and digital
um ryan adams uh signifier ceo was uh
was there at the time so great character
um you know straight away gravitated
towards his
his um his mindset and um it was
literally focusing on
um small teams you know that was
literally it there was you know
like i said 16 17 people there my team
that i joined there was only two people
like the the manager at the time and
another guy that actually
got me the interview at console i saw i
met him down the gym one night and he
said you know
we're hiring because i said i was
interviewing at another place so um
yeah so two interviews that day so yeah
it's very very small business
when i left the business uh earlier this
year
it was uh 80 people
uh global offices in the us
two in the us and and one in in uk
london
uh the team size was around it was
around 45 people in
in my division still um and then in the
permanent side as well very very similar
numbers so
yeah it went through a crazy amount of
growth in a
fairly short amount of time um and i'll
be grateful for that forever you know
hit sort of starting a business a fairly
new fresh start-up business
um mark and graham and at the times that
were running the business they they were
very aggressive in where they wanted to
go and they always had their vision so
yeah the vision never changed but um it
was a lot smaller back then to where it
is today
yeah i love that i mean one of one of my
first questions was because
i think um i don't know how many sort of
other recruitment business owners that
you've spoken to and stuff like that but
like i think a typical recruitment story
or dream is that you build up a
recruitment business and sell it right
and and like how how often does that
actually happen i'm not actually sure
from speaking to people on on this
podcast and things like that so i guess
yeah
my first sort of question you were just
touching on it was like why do you think
so console partners were able to achieve
what they did do you think from
from your lens and looking at it from
from your point of view
great question i think console always
seemed to be
one step ahead with the markets so
what i mean by that is that we you know
uh mark at the time
and graham and the leadership team um
we're always looking at like what was
next what was our clients what was our
customers
focusing on in the next two years not
what they were already doing it was like
what's next for example so
and they built their their business
models around that and i think that it
was very effective
very early on because clients um we
would be talking to clients about
technology that they were investing in
um and we would be ready with we've
really made candidates candidates that
either upskilled themselves in that
place so
i think markets were key i think you
know they they were very
futuristic in regards to focusing on
what's next with the clients and
customers
um the technology was was um and still
is today's is a great area you know and
it's always going to be
a need and a focus for clients and
candidates so um you know as we all know
with the tech space we've um
there's it's just it's just crazy what's
going on and what's being
focused on and how and the evolution
what's going on in the next few years so
yes i think that's the key one the
markets
the people you know that was probably
the the best thing about the business uh
ever since there were some amazing
people that worked and still work at
that business
um and from very early on um that bar
was set
very very high you know i used to talk
to um
friends in in the industry and talking
to them about some of the numbers that
um we were doing and and on as a
business
um at a time just a uk business not we
didn't have u.s entities back then
um and some of them were saying blimey
we've you know we've got three offices
and it's
we're not doing that you know and then
also individual um
numbers you know we're well above
average you know averages is
anything between sort of what my average
is slightly higher but i would say
if you're doing 150 a year that seems to
be fairly good
in in in the market you know there was
individuals
in in that market and you know from when
i joined that were doing
three times that four times that you
know with two years three years
experience
and that was because certain individuals
had the right mindset
um it was a competitive working
environment but collaborative
which i think's like which is so
important um for culture
um yeah and i think the people and the
markets i mean there's nothing else
there's no magic answer apart from
really those two
i think they you know the owners done
amazing to keep hold of
um some really good people yeah so
so i've got two very quick questions on
this and then i'm excited to dig into
the sort of the period where you would
just focus on billing for that sort of
four or five year period so
so the first one is uh people may be
listening to this and
sort of may want you to sort of share i
guess a bit more context on
okay dan really great point and
interesting point around emerging
markets or
mark like future being futuristic so i
guess my question to you on that was
like
i don't know one to three things that
you think typically
um they looked for that would that would
give them confidence that it was a
market that they wanted to invest
resources into what i mean i think
that's what people would be interested
in
so i don't know anything that comes up
for you on that yeah of course so
you know one thing we're big on is is
like market intel so understanding like
where we were starting to see trends so
um very early on i was told to
develop like like you know i've still
got it um
today is basically like from twenty four
five years ago is like the market intel
and looking at trends in that market
intel so looking at like what candidates
are talking about where
maybe people are saying where jobs are
going to be what's the focus
um and also what your clients are saying
you know what what is next for them
where are they next invest in um and
then you'll start seeing a repetition
you'll start seeing
technology sort of start coming up and
and from that side and just to keep it
pretty simple is
it's a natural progression you know 3g
is now four four five
5g now you know and that's what i mean
and looking at those trends in
in those markets uh to understand really
where you position yourself
um i think that's really important and
then um
looking at like the amount of leads so
i'm not talking about intel i'm talking
about actual
leads that are coming through candidates
clients for
whatever it is that however whatever
your
way of doing things is everyone has a
slightly different way of doing things
but um
looking at leads and and really
understanding what the market's saying
um and then you can make a real real i
suppose
collective decision with your manager or
whatever it is at a time like this and
this
the market's telling me that this is
going to be big you know this is a real
focus this is going to be a high skill
demand
um and then you're not going into it
really
you know it's a finger in the in the air
sort of thing you've really got an
understanding and you can have real
conversations with new prospective
clients you know and i think that's
where that value add
comes in you can actually take that
conversation to the next level
rather than just saying i've seen you
looking for x i've got why
it's that's you know yes that's
effective in some ways but
clients now are looking for well even
then you know nearly 10 years ago they
were looking for
some something slightly different and
yeah that's how i managed to
to break some some interesting clients
back then that um
you know that helped me to move forward
yeah no that's great and i think what i
love about that is that
for anyone listening just it's just so
important to
have sort of holistic business
conversations right and if you're asking
good questions like
yeah where do you see the market in the
next couple of years or like
just being curious and asking questions
like that you're then not talking about
recruitment and
if you have multiple conversations with
people like that
day in day out well guess what you've
got an amazing insight there
where then when someone doesn't sort of
doesn't speak about the same thing you
can go
actually i've been speaking to these
people and they're sort of thinking
about this what do you think about that
and all of a sudden as you said you're
you're adding value in these things so
great answer on that and then the final
bit you were talking about the people
part so
just the final thing i just wanted to
ask you because i'm always interested is
basically what what do you think were
like the three non-negotiables of the
console culture
um apart from playing five aside now i'm
joking and that was that was about five
and 17.
um non-negotiables i think
work ethic like if you if you wasn't a
hard worker
um you would be shown up because
like any any agency you you know um
there are objectives and you know you
share your successes at the end of the
week you know that that was
that was a a massive thing for console
we would talk about all the
successes and if there was anyone having
a challenge we'd talk about that as a
business
um of course when we were a lot smaller
and we'd all help each other out and
give advice but work if it's key if you
know
you would be um you know definitely
exposed it because everyone was
really focused and honing in on trying
to trying to better their market better
their self
um and trying to push to that common
goal to to take the business to the next
level so the first one's definitely
worth
working um second one is being a good
person
i know i know that sounds a bit cliche
but um
you've got to be a good person right you
know you've got to be approachable in
in in the face you can't let success you
know get
go to your head a little bit you know
the recruitment i call it the
recruitment gods like
recruitment has a funny way of bringing
you back down to earth pretty quickly
um and if you lose track um
of really like what your why is um and
what you know what you're doing here and
also focusing on helping other people
out as well because
you were junior at one point right you
know you you you were asking other
people for help and
i remember this time when i was like you
know four years in three years and i
think it was and um i missed director's
lunch for the first time in i don't know
22 months or something like that she
used to do it every single month
and i went over and i missed director's
lunch by eighteen hundred pounds
and uh i went over and asked um one of
the directors at the time i said like
i'm leaving in here what could i have
done to to do better you know and that's
not because i wanted to look good in
front of the directors it was really
like i must be missing a trick here
because i was doing something before
that i'm not i didn't do this month and
it's affected my
numbers right and it was like i think i
finished on after i said
20 1500 pounds sure some people would
have been really happy with that and
said oh you know what i've
i've still hit well i've achieved my
target for the month
but that just wasn't um where i wanted
to be it's not why i joined recruitment
that wasn't what i wanted to do you know
i didn't want to be
average as such and i'm not saying
there's nothing wrong with that but what
i'm trying to say
my why is is is about
providing for my family which is the
number one priority and and being a good
person
in in that stage so i was combining all
of that and and um
providing for my family and my on my uh
now wife but girlfriend at the time it
was expensive taste i didn't want to
take a step back
just little things like that is that
even at that time when
things are still going well just take a
step back and think
well what could i have done better
because there's there's all there's
always someone out there
that is performing doing better doing
more things more
innovative ideas different ideas that
can generate more business and better
relationships so yeah
yeah nice okay work ethic be good yeah
okay nice
so let's dig into this then so just for
context down for people listening
so you've you've always been a contract
recruiter
so for the first year for four to five
years when you were just focused on
billing before you went into a
more leadership position you was a
contract recruiter
um and i know you said it was market
specific but that with the markets you
did that typically meant that
what locations did you end up sort of
doing business in just for contacts with
people
yeah most of it was um sort of the
nordics
and and sort of germany and belgium and
ireland they were the main
sort of sweet spots for where projects
were at that time
um in in regards to sort of my focus
areas
cool so let always interested to hear
i know you said the standards were high
and there was people doing really well
there but
how how would you describe sort of dan's
first year early years in recruitment
well funny you say that i i i think i
nearly got booted after the first four
weeks
my manager at the time told me that so
it's um
you know i come in into the job um with
with lots of
um enthusiasm um a bit of a yes man
a bit of a you know naturally we all go
through that your manager's giving you
advice
have you got that yeah yeah yeah yeah
all good yeah i know what i'm doing
the first couple of weeks i used to sit
on the phone and like cower a little bit
because i didn't want other people i
thought that people were listening to my
phone calls i don't know why because
nobody was you know it's like
you know they've got their own stuff to
be dealing with but it was just i've
never been in
that type of environment in an office
before so um
the first month i struggled i didn't do
my first resourcing deal for
i think it was eight weeks or something
like that so um
so yeah and then after that it just
clicked
like i kept going i kept getting up that
earlier i was in the
in the office um about quarter to eight
uh half seven quarters away most
mornings because i worked european time
so i knew that i'd normally catch
candidates
at an earlier stage rather than you know
mid morning when they were normally in
meetings
um when they were in the office at the
time when things were normal but um
yeah and then um from that stage yes so
and it just clicked and and and i
suppose the answer was i
started to get a grasp on on what i was
recruiting for
um i started picking up what is how to
actually recruit
you know getting effective with boolean
searches and head hunting
um and really sort of starting to ramp
up speaking to clients so
um see i used to drive my old manager
mad at the times um because
within like eight weeks i was i always
had quite a natural
flair for for business development not
that i knew it at the times
um and i don't know i wasn't good at it
at first but i just i was quite
keen to get on with business development
because i felt that that's where i
needed to be and the business needed
that at that time to be honest and um
yeah so then i moved into i suppose of
junior sales job or junior consultant
job
um in about september time so i had
about
10 weeks of recruiting um my manager's
jobs at the times and then it was sort
of like you need we would go out and
build a business now based on demand and
where we see the markets going
amazing so let's so let's just talk
about
that for a second because i was going to
ask you when did you then yeah go into
more of a 360 role so
look i i i was a permanent recruiter but
from
from the contract recruiters i've
interviewed and met obviously
you still have to do the candidate work
and it's really important to know your
network and spend time with them however
yeah if you it's it you need to get the
projects or you need to get the
businesses and understand what they're
hiring and all these types of things it
seems like yeah if you can get
if you can get very good at winning
business then you back yourself to
to to do the candidate part right but
that's something you've always got to be
constantly
building in terms of your your candidate
pools but it seems like
the key is the the bd side and the
client side
if you're going to be really successful
oh
well i'd argue that now to be fair
because the the way that
everything's moving ahead um you know
there's
there's some really good 180 pillars you
know like
thousand and and candidates for example
is like you know you need
both sides you know you this is part of
the job isn't it yeah you need both
sides on that so
at that particular time i had to go out
and sell there wasn't really another
option because we were building the
business and this what we say we're
building the division
from fairly scratched they were they
were buying customers but there wasn't
really enough
to focus on delivering at that point so
it was more that i
i was in a position that i wanted to do
and also i really wanted to
um to to get out there and build a
business for myself because it
comes back to my wire you know from that
side so i think there's a there's both
aspects to it i think i've met some
incredible
people that have um a 180 model that um
are so much better than than certain
sales people
candidate relationships and that's so
prevalent now
because um those candidates will move
into senior roles you know they will
progress just like
i did with console just like you did you
naturally progress so if you can build
up good tangible relationships early on
and keep in touch with them
add value try and find them newer
positions
um they're naturally at some point going
to be in a higher managing position you
know and that's where that relationship
piece is so key
um so yeah i would argue that you know
it's so both important to have that 360
element
you know you can bring in jobs but if
you can't find the right candidates or
you haven't got the good enough
relationships well you're not going to
you're not going to do
okay cool so i guess but i'll be honest
with you where where
and it's something i definitely
struggled with early on and what
every time i speak to recruiters that
the most popular area that they want to
develop and improve is client
development
that that's just like typically what the
response won't be for everyone but
typically that's where a lot of
recruiters want to improve
yeah which is why i wanted to sort of
ask you around
your sort of client development journey
really so i guess like you just said
you're building this from scratch
like what looking back and maybe you can
speak to recent times as well when
working with your
your team and people but like what what
ended up being your most effective
method of growing your client network
um delivering you know like i said it's
a 460 so
you know most of my clients at that time
um were either system integrators at the
time so they were winning
part of the project from a vendor and
operator and that side so they they were
they were you know from there so needed
needed candidates quickly
but there was also a lot of people that
were in that market in regards to what
they were focusing on but you had to
have your product and that is his
candidates from that side so
you know my first deal i remember it now
was um
i run this hiring manager up um and you
know great guys still speak to him
um today and he said to me listen i've
got i've got an offer on a candidate a
lot
you know i really appreciate your time
um but i'm gonna get the offer out
tomorrow
and you know i had four months
experience probably my naivety at the
times but i said to him what why don't
you just give me tonight
if i can find you someone that's better
than you've got offered
um at the moment would you would you
um be open to reviewing that profile and
he said if you can find me someone
better than that then i'll shake your
hand because this guy that i've got at
the moment is amazing
i don't know what to do next so i
literally five o'clock in the evening
um i've got on the um i've reached out
to my network and system and stuff like
that and uh
luck luckily have it this is incredible
um panda that said to me yeah i am
actually interested in looking
not sure on the location um need some
time to think about it so i said okay
cool well
we'll do some research tonight sent him
a load of bonfires in the office till
late that night and i gave him i said he
free for a call uh in the morning first
thing and he said yeah yeah no worries
and uh
he spoke to um his partner and said yeah
listen let's go for this you know i'm
looking to get into some more
into freelancing now contracting get the
profile over and the manager responded
within two minutes and i don't know how
you've done that but i want to interview
this guy he's got product knowledge that
we haven't seen this other guy hasn't
got it
and they interviewed him that day and
offered him that evening
just it was it was crazy but that's
again like having
it was definitely naivety from my side
but also
you know just asking the question a lot
of people just don't ask the question
you know and and and backing yourself a
little bit and um
it might it might have uh come back to
bite me but fortunately
um the candidate i've placed numerous
times throughout the years
years as well and he's actually a good
friend of mine now as well so
you know it all works out in the end but
sometimes just ask a question on that
side for sure but yeah
so so building on that then so you said
sort of just delivering there and
backing yourself but like
i guess a big part um of what recruiters
need to do is
is maintaining and sort of keeping a
consistent pipeline
yeah how how did you how did you
continue to achieve that
i suppose firstly the obvious is
bringing in business constantly
like you know it was natural um
at that period like if i had and you
know knowing your ratios it was key you
know in your numbers what you need to do
to hit x
you know why and um at any given time
i'd be juggling
when i was 360 for example between eight
and twelve vacancies a week you know
that was naturally and
um that was accounts that i've built up
and and and built relationship with and
that was warm and that's also new
new areas that i wanted to bring in new
clients so consistently
looking at your customer base and if you
know reviewing that on a monthly basis
if you've got a customer
you've only got one or two a customers
and you've got a lot of c b or c
customers
what do you need to do to get those to a
customers so so what i mean by a
customers is that
are they buying from you monthly are
they do they have jobs
is it um are they decision makers loads
of different areas and
just keep reviewing your business
because customers that i might have
worked with in january
could have been on my d list by by
march or april because they maybe not
been hiring or they weren't the right
quality and i think
timing your time is so so precious on
that side so really
understanding you know are your clients
buying
do they do they really value what you're
doing and can you deliver you know
there's no point working jobs that you
don't really know what you're talking
about because
you know that's that you know they're
you're gonna you're gonna lose a
relationship there that
from that side okay so so let's just
talk about time
quickly because this is something that a
lot of people
like you just said you're juggling a lot
of things there right yeah and i think
as recruiters that that's something that
you have
to just try and improve at consistently
yeah um so i guess from a sort of
from you sort of becoming a um
successful contract builder i guess
people want to know like how you
how you run your day to get the most out
of it so you're talking about it there
like your time is really precious which
is where this question
comes from and why why people want to
know it so like
from from your journey like what again
what became your sort of typical day or
what did you do day in day out to make
sure that
you maximized your time sure so
the first thing i'd say is the best
recruiters permanent contract doesn't
matter where who
you know what markets you're focusing on
keep it simple
like they don't over complicate it and
you know um
the amount of times that i've when i was
mentoring or when i was managing and
leading
um the division is that people were over
complicating it all the times and really
you've just got to have
a rule on like a checklist every day
every single day before you go is like
what do you want to achieve from that
day so it could be
follow-ups reverse markets calls
leads to chase whatever it is but having
a real understanding right what do i
need to get my business to to what does
my business
need tomorrow so you know if you're
focused on 180
how many more candidates do i need to
get at interview stage
to put myself in a position to hit my
target this month
and if you're more business development
focuses how many more vacancies or how
many new customers do i need to develop
and bring in
so that i can hit my target on that side
so that's the two fundamentals right and
what sits underneath that
is all of the stuff that we've already
spoke about whether it's you know how do
you build a business well
you know that's or how do you build how
do you get candidates you know it's
building relationships and
speaking speaking to them so keeping it
simple
so i know and like i said it's it's so
important
because i've worked with some really
really intelligent people
so so intelligent people and the amount
of times i've gone into the meeting and
said like where
where's where is your day plan like
where is what do you want to achieve
today
what does your business need and they
can't answer it because they're just
it's just so on top of them and once you
take it back and you simplify
what it is your business needs or what
it is whatever you know business
business requirements from that side
then you can make a checklist and then
you can really have a tangible
conversation with your manager
and say listen my business ain't need
this any good manager will
will challenge you um and hopefully
point you in a direction but also you
both agree that that is the right way to
go
but also more importantly is that i i
was coming up with the answers you know
i wasn't going to my manager and going
i've got this problem i don't know what
to do it's like going away and thinking
about it so
simplifying it having a strict process
in regards to what you're focusing on
for your day and the only time you
should move away from that day plan or
process
is that you've got a client or an
interview that's fallen through and you
need to get back to
focusing on supplying that candidate but
or supplying that vacancy at that time
but
but yes i know i know it sounds
easier said than done don't get me wrong
because everyone knows that it's just
simplifying everything that you do and
just having a good checklist of what you
want to achieve and what your business
needs
amazing and people look i'm asking this
because people want to know
yeah sure like what so at the height of
the height of when you were doing really
well
like i'm sure you know because it's
rinse and repeat but like what
just taught me through like a a typical
day plan for dan
like yeah because people want to know it
first thing in the morning would be
going through
um any responses um from adverts
or linkedin responses that i would have
sent out the night before in regards to
focus it uh for the jobs that i've got
live
uh next one would be then business
development calls like straight
straight into it um with an event
let's just let's just let's add time so
let's just add times
just yeah just it will just make it
really clear because people people love
this mate people want to know
so what time to start responses what
time do you get in and then what time
yeah eight o'clock in the morning
between quarter to eight and eight
o'clock in the morning um
straight away looking through to be
honest i used to do a lot of that on my
phone so
when i was when i was traveling in my
travel journey was about 40 minutes i'd
be
looking at responses making notes
sending emails to myself for reminders
um and calendar invites for myself to
focus on
when i get in and then i walk through
the door uh breakfast and then and then
straight into it i would have a
list of clients or prospects that i want
to speak to
once i've gone through like i said the
initial candidates etc i would then be
on the phone
at quarter half eighth quarter tonight
at that very latest
speaking to um to clients and pitching
in
leads reverse markets what whatever
leads i've got to follow up from
that would normally take me it would
take me as long as long as i needed
you know um if if i needed business i'd
do it all day
that would be it i'd be doing it all day
and that wouldn't be just
calling clients that would be calling
candidates asking well what they up to
clients that i've got relationships new
candidates that i'm focusing on because
i needed vacancies so the best way to do
that is to talk
is to reach out to people and understand
that um if i had vacancies in the
afternoon that i'd work on
and then from two to um like two till
five
be focusing on supplying those those
vacancies like you know and then
getting leads market intel anything that
i need for the morning or the evening
whatever it is having that ready to go
and then at five o'clock um in any
administration
reverse markets go out the door day plan
um and that's it and then go again and
then of course the next day i might have
four urgent vacancies
business development um would be less
i'd only do sort of an hour's hour or
two hours just to follow up my leads to
keep
keep it ticking over and then focus on
um supporting candidates but
every single day was business
development whether i was talking to
candidates or clients and i think that's
where some people get it wrong is that
you know
whether you're 180 or whether you're
360. it's so important that
you're still retaining information from
people and you're either giving that to
the relevant people in your business
that
are more focused on sales or you make a
note and you action it
later on down the line whether that's
later in the day or the next
or the following um following day but so
some point doesn't matter what level you
are whether you're one day
in or 10 years in you should be
business developing every single day a
week whatever level you are
yeah nice great i think you yeah it's
i've had a guy on here called nick
carmen before and he the way he coins it
is like yeah
always be open for business instead of
like putting the sort of blinders on
between 10 and 12 you're just doing
business development and then when
you're doing two till five
candidates like you've got again the
blinders on and you're just focusing on
their reasons for leaving
rather than asking about the projects
they have on and like it's stuff like
that right so
yeah i love that so just just really
thanks for sharing that because that's
what people want to
find out so i guess what um before we
move on to the
the sort of um the sort of uh
non-billing
journey that you went on really quickly
because p this just helps with like
how you went on your journey so what
what what ended up being your best year
billings wise
as a contract recruiter uh billions year
was
about it was just under 800 um
so it's about was your best yeah yeah
best year it's about 765 something like
that i think that was 2015.
um so the year before
and then and then just and then this
ties into the question but and then
i don't know the sort of years leading
up to that what did this sort of
performance look like
um so over that period so the first so
like i said june to
um december was my first half i suppose
like three months of that i'd done i
think it was like three or four deals
um in that period most of those were
december
um so that was like of course 2011 but
that gave me that confidence and that
momentum coming into 2012
first year was about 275 um
that was from a fairly standing start
clients that i worked in december
actually didn't have much repeat
business so that was sort of new new
projects
um and then second year was um
funny enough me and ryan adams at the
time were going toe to toe to like he'll
remember that story as well i uh
you know i think it was january february
i um i was talking to a client
that was uh at the time gonna be a big
project i needed a number of people and
um i had a good candidate base and i
supplied a number of candidates and
and i think i've done 104k um
which is so i've sort of
set it out pretty early on which i'm
really proud of you know from that side
yeah
that was sort of breaking record in
regards to what the business knew and um
i suppose putting that bar to the next
level you know um from that side but
still saying very grounded
you know i wanted to be top biller um
that's what i looked at from day one
um you know ryan was keen to get that
top bill of status as well so
and i'll say it on the record he picked
me on the last day by about 3k
but we went home right to the end and um
that was good and then that set me up
and then the year after
um it was about 6.95 so actually i had
my best
year was 2012 to 20 2013
i added about 300k to my business and
then 2014
was i done 690 um which was about
another 120 530 from the year before
and then like i said in 2015 was seven
mid mid 700s so um but yeah so it was a
really good
natural progression forward um
but yeah no no it's good fun good fun
thank you for sharing that and and the
re the reason why i ask isn't isn't to
try and sort of get you to show if your
numbers but the most popular question i
get is
like if you and i'm sure you've had this
with your guys now i mean talk about the
non-billion piece but
like recruiters want to know how to how
to take it up a notch
right because a lot of recruiters may
look at the end of the year it's like
wow i've had a good year
last year i did 150k just did 200k
but a lot of people may think right how
the hell am i going to squeeze
like how am i going to get more out of
what what i currently have to go what
i'm in
um yeah so so i guess just the final
thing on this is like
looking back at that and you can sort of
reference maybe things that you see
with people that you've held to stuff
like that but most common thing people
don't know is like
what what do you think were the sort of
main one to two things that you did
differently maybe didn't do anything
differently but like
what were the sort of core things that
you really doubled down on
that you really felt meant that you was
able to
continue increasing your performance and
yeah grow that
to nearly 800 100k billions like what
what did you really double down on that
you really felt
enabled you to achieve that i think the
first thing is
i didn't over complicate it you know i i
really
from that side i knew what i wanted to
do i set i set a goal out at the start
of the year
and i wanted i had to hit there was no
there was no other way
um because of where i want to be in my
life and
what i want to achieve there wasn't room
for
well you know i've had a good year
that's just not not
in my makeup in my dna um to
to be on that side and and that's just
me as a person you know i'm either all
in and all out you know and
if i'm all in i'm going to put it at the
start of the year that listen i need to
hit that that goal so
whether or not i had 50 to do that in in
three months or
or 10 over that i had to hit that goal
anything over that was
was an achievement in my eyes anything
if i hit that
that was where i needed to be that
wasn't an achievement in my eyes you
know i didn't
i hit what i needed to hear but
overachieving that
that was when then i thought you know
what yeah it was a good year you know i
take that on porto
having high expectations of yourself not
looking at anyone else you know
of course you've got great peers around
me that we we would work together on on
on different elements to it
but compete with yourself that's the key
thing look at yourself and think
what can i do can i can i push myself
can i get better at
converting leads um can i get better at
my ratio in regards to interviews
whatever it is and
if you just look at yourself you don't
have a complicated because you're not
really
you know great you know someone's done a
40k that's going to drive you on
but you're competing with yourself on
that side in in in your own way of
course recruitment have lead tables and
stuff like that but
um you know naturally when you see
people get to the top
um they can they can drop off i've seen
it
people will drop off because they've got
no one to compete to but if you're
competing against yourself
then you know you can just keep
progression and i know it sounds simple
but it's like literally just pushing
yourself all the time
um relating back to your goals like one
of the best bidders
recently um who's still at console now
he has his goals he writes his goals out
every single day
every single day without doubt he has
his goals set up what he wants to
achieve he's not really
focused on what other people are doing i
think that's such an important trait
um in any sales involvement no
recruitment anything
and not just sales in life you know
focus on what you can do
you know and and achieve where you can
focus on and control
okay final thing again people don't know
the answer to this
i think a lot of people want to know
this sort of secret source
but yeah or like this sort of golden
golden bullet but
obviously it doesn't exist it's a
multiple things but
like people want to know you spoke about
keeping it simple and
and these things so what do you think is
the the most important action or kpi
that that contributes to
a recruiting success well deals
right you know like it's it's it's this
you know that again keeping it simple
like if
you know you as a sales individual like
sales i'm talking
collectively you know any any elements
within a sales environment
you are you know your commission is
based on sales
progression is is 80 to 90
based on sales in in a sales environment
so i suppose the first one again you can
look at interviews but
how many deals have i done or what how
many deals have you done you know that's
the first thing is that that naturally
of course from a agency point of view
is that that you can judge in your
success um
from that side and i don't know if
that's the answer you wanted to but
again it's simple it's
you know it deals from that side it's i
think i think it's the bit before that
right so i guess it's the bit where
you're talking about keeping it simple
so i guess
people want to know like going into a
brand new month it's like right if i
know if i get i don't know if i know if
i have x
meaningful conversations with potential
clients i should hit my
number or yeah i don't know if i if i
get x number of in like
x number of interviews first stage
interviews i know i'm confident
it's just people want to know like where
to really double down on the action
yeah i think the the taking one step
back of course is
you know any successful um
individual within a recruiting
recruiting space will know will know
their numbers like what what are their
sweet spots and
if you don't know their sweet spots and
that's really important that you talk to
your manager or your director and
and you carve that out together and you
really understand what
what is what what are your sweet numbers
it changes right because you're hoping
that they they decrease over a while
because you get more effective right
because your clients get more effective
when i started for example i was
averaging
um and my way of doing it i wasn't very
good on
uh with emails and reverse market i
enjoyed phone interactions or like
so i was doing anything between three
and three and four and a half hours a
day on the phone
you know like naturally that's where i
needed to be some of them were pointless
conversations they probably could say i
could definitely be more
focused on on um on that area but
for me that's what worked you know that
what you know that for me that's what
got me to where i needed to be but
you know for for example um
naturally five vacancies a week
15 to 16 submissions a week um
and eight interviews if i got that i
would be on to
four or five contract deals a month you
know and people would say this was going
back to
sort of 2012 2013 you know
maybe i could reduce that but that's
where you would look at you with your
manager and um and they were really big
on that console was what can you tweak
what can you do
so those are the types of ratios you
know two to one ratio and anything that
you're trying to do
yeah no thank you for sharing that so
let's um
conscious all the time but let's get
into
the sort of towards the tail end because
i think this is what also i know we've
focused a lot on recruiting but a lot of
recruiters listen to this and
i think what you've shared is really
interesting for people so i guess
like why didn't would you mind just sort
of sharing
i guess look what we wanted to go over
when we spoke about this was like
one how you how you felt like you got
the opportunity presented to you to get
sort of equity shares in a recruitment
business
yeah um so let's talk a bit about this
before we finish because i think
most aspirational recruitment recruiters
that listen to this will even maybe one
day think about potentially starting
their own recruitment business
or typically it's they want to be a
director in the company they work for
and
maybe sort of get the opportunity to own
part of that company or
etc so let's just start there so one
like why don't we talk about why do you
think dan cox was able to
get the opportunity to get offered
equity shares in this recruitment
business rather than your peers because
as you said
super competitive landscape there's
great people in there
why was you able to do that firstly um
so i'll get i'll get graham and mark on
the phone see if they can
no i think
they were very good in regards to where
um like looking after top performers and
and
trying to suppose lock them in you know
towards the company vision and the
company goal
that wasn't without saying that i asked
a question you know again like i
mentioned earlier on about when i've
done my first deal i
sort of i knocked on the door one day
and um
i said what what opportunities within
the business but again i've never worked
in
in a company like you know recruitment
company before so you know naively going
into there and saying
what what is the opportunity to be part
of this journey more longer term you
know and that side so
they went away and talked about a few
things so a lot of it was down
when did you do that um probably around
2015 2015 time i picked my time right
because i was i was
still in good numbers um you know i
think that
you'd have a tougher conversation if you
weren't performing and you went in and
asked for shares for your company so you
have to get the timing right
um but yeah around that time and and for
me i wanted to be more
part of the part of the business and the
opportunity
i i really i love that business still
today
um and for me i wanted to be part of it
you know
and however that looks whatever that
would look so that was down to
the owners at the time to to to keep
that focused and
also probably on their side they they're
they're aware of
i suppose how you know where i want to
be in my life at some point you know
what
what i want to achieve um in in the
recruiting industry you know
and then that's really important that
you know they maybe saw that so you know
from that time time it was key
asking the question again that you've
got to be speaking to your
to your managers uh apologies to any
managers that might be getting bombarded
by recruiters next week but
it's really important that you you know
as a business you want to understand
what opportunities on the table
you know to be part of that um that
growth model
um from that side so yeah so that's
that's really important
you know i'm glad you like honestly this
keeps coming up time and time again like
if you're listening to this and
and you have leverage right and not not
you don't have like you're you're
someone that you think can add a lot of
value to the to the business you work
for long term you really enjoy working
there you bought into what it's about
like
i'll ask the question like literally
like
why yeah so the worst case scenario is
no not at this time or whatever but at
least yeah you're making them
you're making people aware that's what
you want right so when
your sort of managers or business owners
start thinking about right how
how can we grow this business how can we
keep our best people
oh you know what dan actually reached
out to me three months ago and said look
if there's an opportunity to own part of
this company be part of it longer term
like count me in or at least consider me
so like if you listen to this and you
haven't
asked the question like the worst case
scenario is not a bad thing so i'm glad
you said that but i guess the next thing
i wanted to ask you dan was because i
think sometimes
recruiters when i've spoken to them they
can be a bit sort of blindsided by this
or
just don't have complete clarity on what
it actually means
right so when we say you end up getting
offered equity shares like
could you just share sort of with people
listening like one what does it actually
mean and two
like what sort of tip i know it may be
specific to your circumstances and what
happened but like
typically you can talk about your
experience but like tip
what what did that mean and what sort of
things had to sort of happen
for you to really reap the rewards of
actually having equity shares in the
business so i think not many people are
completely clear on this
yeah absolutely so equity is actually
having
registered i suppose shares with with
the organization
so you you know you're part of the
dividends payments on the profits for
for the organization from that side
and i think really important when i when
i was first offered those it was a
really proud moment for me because
um it felt like i was actually
part of the vision and the business and
i think that's so key in regards to
natural progression you know it gave it
another
another focus point you know i'm
actually a shareholder of this
multi-million pound organization um
i need to be making sure that i am
focusing on bringing the next level of
staff through and
i suppose positioning myself that it can
be achieved like you know i'm not
nothing special from anyone else you
know
like i mentioned earlier are asking the
question from that side so equity shares
are a little bit tougher to get hold of
of course because um
there's various constraints that you
need to be aware there's emi schemes as
well
and the companies and a lot of good
companies now are
are offering that out and i think the
way that you position it and
you talk to you know your your uh
managers or directors and saying i'm
really bought into the vision
you know which you are because you're
sitting there and you're working and
you're succeeding
um but i want to understand the future
growth of this business and um
and understand if i can be part of it
and it's
it sounds like it could be a negative
conversation sometimes but
the amount of um like the positive
response and i can only talk on my
behalf but
um the positive response i got from it
was like i love it
loving that you want to be part of that
business you know and you're you're not
thinking about anything else and
they they were open arms about it and um
and said yeah let's let's try and make
this work
we'll come back to you and that was it
so you know it was all around time on
that side but there are
various ways that you can be part of the
business of course and
it does feel special it's nice when
you're part of the business and
you know if you have a good positive
year and profits are higher
of course like any shareholder you can
buy shares tomorrow in any company you
get you read the awards of the
dividends and etc but um you just more
importantly i felt part of
of the of the story you know and and
that that was really important to me at
that time that um
where i wanted to be yeah cool
so get that complete and that that's
great thank you for sharing that so i
guess
she's spoken about yeah being able to as
an employee
um you wouldn't get obviously access to
the profits of the overall business
right
from dividends etc but sort of to really
benefit from
the equity piece and having equity
shares like just just really simply what
what was best case scenario so you guys
ended up getting
um acquired but like just for people
listening so they can have a bit of an
understanding of right so
if i'm able to yeah try and potentially
have um
yeah become a shareholder or get on some
sort of scheme
what what what if you could just explain
like just from your experience and what
you went through
what was the best case scenario what
events had to happen for you to really
benefit from
becoming a shareholder yeah i think i
think there's a really good question
um shares are in
in a business for example outside of
dividends and stuff like that and
profitability
you know shares are only really valuable
if the company
has a real focus and vision on um being
acquired one day
you know because you could be a
shareholder but they're pretty
outside of being part of the business
and the vision they're pretty you know
pointless if
if the company's not really got the
management or the directors that own
that place haven't got
a focus on on on on selling you know at
some point acquiring and stuff like that
so
again you need to speak to you know
either the owners or your manager and
understand what is the vision plan
you know like um from that business um
so that you can support that focus
um yeah i suppose that that's the key
bit is that you know really
understanding what what the vision is
for the business
um and then once you are required what
does that mean you know because of
course
acquiring a business normally means that
they want to take that business to the
next level it doesn't mean are they just
going to cash out and leave
it's like what do they want to do next
they want to expand into
six more countries globally they want to
they want to build out the us market
whether that's contract or permanent
they want to become a global staffing
provider you know from from that side so
um and sometimes the directors
don't have experience in doing that you
know and that's why they need to go to
that
that you know that next level up and
saying listen for part of my business
can you help us get to the next level
so yeah that's that's a big driver of
course with equity that
you know if the company does go through
a purchase then
you know however small they are then you
know their [ __ ] those shares will be
realized at some point
yeah no good thanks to yeah no thanks
for going through that because i think
sometimes people can sort of get
confused by that and i think the other
point to make which is again
quite quite popular and common and we've
had a couple of people go through this
on the podcast
is then the sort of management buyout
route right where
again it's it's actually then the the
way that that
the original founders or owners of the
company get out is by actually selling
the company to
over to people that have been there for
a long time etc right
so i think what what sort of down the
sharing here with you all is that
it's about asking the question it's
about communicating it's about
understanding where the business is
going
and if you ask those questions and
they're willing to have those
conversations then
yeah you can really actually understand
what yeah things could actually mean and
what the positive outcomes could be
and yeah so thank you so i've got
before i ask you sort of five final
questions i just want to ask you one
thing
so what what advice would you give
yourself
um to dan cox just entering the
recruitment industry so
i i just want to know from what you've
been through right um
if you could communicate and have a
conversation with dan cox who
first day in recruitment after a couple
of days graduating uni
what would you what would you say to
yourself um
don't sweat the small things i think
that massive like i used to let
i used to let the smallest of things in
my day affect me for
you know a couple of hours you know and
i think that's massive you know
at some point you've just got a soak it
up push on
and it affects you you know that that
you can't most of the time you can't
change a certain outcome
if that's where it is um but you can
um you can change the end result and i
think that's really important to
understand you know yet
a candidate for example might have
dropped out or might have
you know offer a checked you still got
that vacancy or you still got that
client and um
go and find someone that is focused on
that so yeah definitely that one for
sure
uh don't switch one it's a good question
because i
i tell myself to run as well no i'm
joking
no joking i love the industry though
and i think
really really get to know your market um
really know where your market's going
um so that you can have earlier tangible
conversations because probably for the
first three four months
um i was going in um a little bit
blindsided in regards to
speaking to some great people and but
they probably thought that and i did
sound probably fairly junior so
just a little bit research you know
understanding your marketing a little
bit more so they're
probably the two key things nice
so last last questions for you so first
one
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
um i think the key one is
be proud of being a recruiter yeah it's
i used to do it as well is that
i'd be around certain individuals that
had you know amazing sounding jobs
you know like stock brokers or
insurance brokers and i'd say what do
you do recruitment and i think at times
i used to be a little bit embarrassed
about that and i don't know why
because if you actually look at the
industry and what it
and what it supports and what it means
is all the good parts of course i know
there are some bad parts of
the industry from that side but i think
definitely people be proud of
of working in the industry because i
think it does it adds so much value
not just to the economy to companies to
businesses
um from that side so yeah definitely
don't don't do what i've done and be
you know just a little bit embarrassed
when i was earlier on because
my job sounded a little bit a bit better
whatever a bit more interesting but
actually
you think about what you do as a
recruiter day in day out
um it's pretty cool yeah
next one what what book have you read
that has had the biggest impact on you
if you don't read could be a problem you
know what that was
my goals the last probably for two or
three years but really
um focusing on reading books like rich
dad poor dad
by far in regards you probably hear that
a lot right but that really
impacted um and probably cliche as well
really impacted
my relationship with with money um
and focusing on
assets that can provide cash flow
and to support the future because of
course
i know what i can do with recruitment
but no one can
control for example the economy and
where that's going to be but if you've
got
cash flowing assets from that side and
using your money
um then hopefully later on in life um
you know that's that you should be
fairly set up on that side so yeah that
was a
massive massive influence into where i
focus my
time and outside of recruiting as well
nice bit of a different one this one
what what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
uh for me myself yeah because i think my
wife probably got the first big big girl
there's always normally sort of not
always but sometimes there's a typical
sort of memorable
thing that you ended up buying um
probably yeah probably my um my range
rover
so like um i went out and got it
probably about two years in
into the business i'd always dream of
having it it's my dream car
i love i love that range rover sports
it's just
ever since even though i was at uni i
used to say to my uni friends and
friends
i'm gonna drive one of them you know i'm
going to drive one of them and they need
to laugh and say
listen you're massively overdrawn you've
got loads of debt what are you going on
about
yeah that was that was an amazing
feeling being
you know getting into that car for the
first time and um
and i'd achieve that you know no one
else i'd achieved that
and um yeah it was great amazing even
though it was a depreciation asset it
was just
you know one of the things that i'd
always wanted early on you know
yeah no i love that last question
and look this this this may be something
that you're sort of
sort of working through now and stuff
but just still interested i guess
what's the sort of old i typically ask
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
or you can sort of answer that just your
career now what comes up for you what's
the ultimate goal for your career
giving back 100 um
i want to be able to be in a position at
some point in my career where i can
give advice offload experience is it
what i've done well what i've not done
so well from
um and having that platform to um
be able to give back to the industry um
in whatever whatever shape or form that
is
um it's definitely giving back nice love
that dan
i'm i'm sure there's loads more that we
could go into but i thought that was
brilliant i think you've been on a
great great journey and um really
excited for people to
to listen to this so thanks a lot for
coming on the show
no no ways thank you any time been a
pleasure